oh I miss you too baby but don't worry
we can be together now forever yeah I
miss you shark
[Music]
well I guess this is my fate now so okay
okay hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to Octodad
now you guys thought that it was over
and I thought that nightmare was over
know how I did this but here I am so
there is more content in Octodad that I
have not yet played and it is a secret
level that you guys have told me about
and I'm just gonna wallow in Agni as I
try to make my way into the men's room
excuse me I need to drop a few tons here
so I was actually dangerously close to
finding the secret it's just weird do
you do not like my shark body hmm okay
so I was actually extremely close to
finding out this dark and dirty secret
you put one leg in the toilet and flush
okay okay alright then crisis over what
how how how would anyone have possibly
gotten themselves into that situation
I do not know okay so one Ling in your
flush you go down like a normal normal
octopus not even a normal human layer
normal octopus would so you wind up in
this dark shadow this episode has
already gone awry and I'm not even a
minute into it I may be a minute into it
I have no idea so anyway this is as far
as I saw I just saw the entrance I don't
know what else here is to it you push
the red button that's it that's all I
saw
rest is a mystery to me and frankly the
beginning was a mystery to me as well
but here I go
Oh joyous day at least I don't have to
worry about three-dimensional movement
but something tells me that I'm not
gonna like this very much move move move
move
now now now is the time for action now
is the time for adventure oh good good
good that that felt good I like the way
that felt across my tentacles and my
suckers so I don't exactly know what the
objective here is I probably could have
reached up and pushed that button before
but I'm just gonna oh I get it
oh I see okay so and you to raise my
right leg and put it inside oh that is
clever oh that is clever and let my leg
drop reach over to be top reach in
switch legs drop leg no oh oh no oh no
ha ha ha
I can't let me be beat or you can't beat
me I have no idea what I'm talking about
all I know is that I'm kind of doing
this so if everyone can shut up for two
seconds and let me concentrate oh yeah
how does that even happen I do not even
want to know okay come on come on why
not why not why not why not why not
what no no no no what am I doing wrong I
was perfect for like a long time there I
was perfect I was doing it's doing
perfectly well okay so let that drop
don't let it touch they drop they touch
why why not there why not there what are
you doing I don't even know you're just
undulating your foot tentacles so that
you can undulate the button me there's a
lot of undulation going on but
undulation is that what I need to do Oh
central movements of my toe this is not
helping this is not helping anyone god
damn it just get up why is this one so
hard Reed's with your tentacle and push
it yes okay why was that so hard
what you got to make things difficult
for me and pretty much any sure that any
other any other I have not seen any
other youtuber play this but I'm pretty
sure that any other youtuber playing
this game does not have nearly as much
trouble as I do just just just to guess
okay so oh I see I'm supposed to climb
up the other side and then Winky dory
I'm not even let I'm not even touching
anything why are you grabbing on why are
you grabbing on why are you grabbing on
I'm not touching anything you go under
like a normal squid Lulu and venture up
into the exit you gotta get three cool
ties any minute now
if you got just you operate with me
all you need to do is literally nothing
you need to do nothing nothing nothing
you just need to do nothing you need to
do nothing just need to rest your food
[Music]
any other time any other time you would
literally stick to anything no you will
not okay all right getting a little too
frustrated when I get frustrated I get
flustered which means that again play
properly which means that it's not gonna
cooperate with me I wanted to do is
cooperate with me all you need to do is
let your foot stay there that is
literally all you need to do you need to
do nothing else but let your foot stay
there ha ha how are you not how are you
not what are you doing I don't want four
cheese's let's check that the one for
this way I don't care but I have a
chance have a chance
let me over
[Music]
back in the shark tank so that I can
endless the wave began I think I'm even
beginnings talk it's like who's that me
back in I love you so much
just please cherish me for all this I'm
worth I know it's not much our love is
not meant to be but I've left my wife
let us make beautiful I don't know what
would you make I made a human with a
human sir
let's make shark babies let's make
all-natural shockwaves serrano a little
children run away from our love
does it seem strange to you in any way
Oh mr. human I like you you don't judge
love this tight bond is this well that's
the end of us here's my lovely wife over
there
please dear no you're not my wife I
don't need a wife anymore I've got my
shark hello you like my disguise don't
worry about me just gonna make my way
into the aquarium her
can I make it seems a bit stock I
finally become the shark oh isn't it a
good way oh yay I'm free to be whoever I
want
I'm free to be normal take my picture
I'm a normal human
look at me dance
[Music]